Hi. My name is Margaret Gardel and I run a biophysics lab at the
University of Chicago. Today I am going to tell you about my favorite
problem at the interface of biology and physics.
When you first learn about cells, you think about the structure and
function of individual organelles. What you learn much less about is
the stuff that takes up the rest of the space within the cell known as the
cytoplasm. They cytoplasm is about 50% water. The rest of the
volume is filled with densely packed globular protein, small organelles,
and dense filamentous networks known as the actin, microtubules and
intermediate filament cytoskeletons. So this complicated material
can be thought of as a complex fluid or visco-elastic solid.
The fact that you could call it either liquid or a solid depends.
It is said that it's mechanics on both the length and time scales you are
considering. This field of soft condensed matter physics is well equipped
to build physical models of such complicated materials.
The fact that the cytoplasm is made up of macromolecules
means that thermal effects are going to be important.
If we now go down to the scale of individual proteins, we can, in this
animation, can start to see the effects of thermal energy at this
nanometer length scale. You see these randomized motions of
individual macromolecules known as Brownian motion
drives random agitation and collisions between macromolecules.
You also get a sense of how crowed the cytoplasm is.
All soft material have this type of thermal effects at play
and so we have really built physical models of such soft
materials in the physical world.
What makes the cytoplasm unique is it also contains an abundance
of mechanoenzymes. That is proteins that can convert chemical energy
to do mechanical work. An excellent example of this is molecular motors.
Here is a movie and animation of a motor protein, kinesin, walking
along a microtubule track. Right, the kinesin is taking in a chemical
energy source and is using that to do mechanical work, to drive its
motility and generate local stresses. The fact that the cytoplasm
contains all of these mechanoenzymes means that there is an
external energy source in addition to just thermal effects. This drives
the cytoplasm out of thermodynamic equilibrium
and makes it a very unique material.
So the cytoplasm is this soft material that is driven far from
thermodynamic equilibrium. It has no analogs of
similar types of material in the physical world. This means that new
physics is required understand the physics of the cytoplasm.
I'm going to talk you briefly about two examples
of where physics can play an important role in understanding
aspects of cell physiology. The first is intercellular transport.
For many different aspects of life process in a cell, they have to
move organelles and molecules from one side of the cell to the other.
The types of cargo that need to be transported range from
small molecules like water to up to micron size organelles.
Now if we just think about thermal forces and diffusion
it's incapable of moving even the smallest cargo over very
large distances in a reasonable time.
Therefore you need motor proteins transport this cargo
along the filamentous tracks. Now if the cytoplasm
were just simply water, the effective drag felt on any
of these cargo would be negligible and motor proteins
could do this quite easily. However the cytoplasm is this
very complex environment and these cargo are going
to feel very large resistances. How do motor protein overcome
this problem to really effectively move cargo?
So if we just think about cargo moving in the cytoplasm,
depending on your size, you are going to feel a different local
environment. Small molecules are going to be able to diffuse
rapidly and go in between spaces of globular proteins
whereas large cargo are going to be effectively trapped.
This means that the type of material you are considering
in the cytoplasm really depends on the landscape you are looking at.
It will mostly be liquid like at small length scales and it will appear
like a solid at long length scales. This transition between a liquid and
solid occurs at length scales relevant to organelles. Most proteins
will experience a liquid like environment whereas chromosomes
will experience a more solid like environment.
Now how does a cell stay well mixed to be able to transport all of its objects and
and get them in the right place in the right time?
Well one recent idea is that the enzymatic activity within the cytoplasm
actually serves to mix the cytoplasm up. This is akin to
the convective mixing you see a pot of water on a stove top.
Right, that eviction really mixes the water in a way that much
better than diffusion. So this act of stirring is then thought to liquidize
the cytoplasm over all the relevant length scales
so the chromosomes also feel a liquid like environment.
Now the question is does the enzymatic activity really stir the cytoplasm
and is it possible that this enzymatic activity could be regulated
to regulate the amount of stirring during different times of the
cell metabolism. That is could a cell effectively transition
itself from being liquid like to solid like depending on its life stage?
The second example I would like to talk about is in cell morphogenesis.
At the outer cell membrane, there is a dense network of
filamentous proteins known as the actin cortex and this actin cortex
is responsible for cell shape changes you see during cell division,
cell migration and tissue morphogenesis.
So what is the mechanics of this outer polymer network
that enables a cell to do these robust shape changes?
So to get an idea of what this actin cortex looks like
you can see this fluorescence microscopy image of a reconstituted actin cortex
where actin filaments are labeled in red. You can see it is quite dense.
Over a 100 micromolar. And it is a very thin, dense sheet of actin at
at the plasma membrane. And so what are the mechanics of
this thin sheet?
Well actin networks are semi-flexible polymers.
And what semi-flexible means is that their banding rigidity is comparable to
thermal energy and the ratio between these two components
gives you a length scale that tells you the persistence length,
the length scales for which the polymer maintains its rigidity
and since this length scale is 17 microns, that means a actin filament
will sometimes behave flexible over larger length scales and
behave more rigid over shorter length scales.
Semi-flexible polymers are almost exclusively found in biological polymers
and confer the networks they form with very unique behaviors not seen
in physical polymer networks and this area of trying to understand how this
semi-flexible affects force transmission is an active area of research.
Secondly, we know that actin filaments are not static but they are actively assembling
and disassembling and so how does this active assembly and disassembly of
the polymers affect their mechanical response to the networks?
We simply just don't have the models that integrate polymerization dynamics
with the mechanics. Some speculation is the polymerization dynamics are
essential for fluidizing the cortex and enabling large shape changes while
maintaining a uniform density during processes like cell division.
So in addition to the actin filaments in the cortex, the main force generators
in the cortex are myosin 2 motors. In this fluorescence image, myosin 2
is seen as an elongated rod and at the molecular scale, these
elongated rods are actually bipolar filaments of myosin 2
motors that drive antiparallel sliding of actin filaments. So these myosin 2 motors
generate local stresses. In contrast to the highly organized circameric structure
actomyosin you seen in striated myofibrils in muscle cells, in non muscle cells
you can see actomyosin is very disorganized. This means the myosin 2 is going to
generate forces that vary in space and time. So we can understand. We can start to
explore how forces get transmitted in this very disorganized network
by reconstituting again these are actin filaments with myosin 2 motors on
top of it and we can start to see these random motions of myosin 2.
So because the actin cytoskeleton has so many
can be controlled spatially, we think that the architecture of the actin cytoskeleton is
regulating the activity of the myosin 2 motors but we simply lack the
models to understand what is driving these types of responses.
And likewise, you can see that the myosin 2 is forming these dense aggregates.
This type of aggregation is not seen in wild type cells and so what in the cytoplasm is
is allowing myosin 2 contractile forces to not concentrate the cytoplasm
in certain regions of the cell.
So I’ve given you two examples of outstanding questions in cell mechanics
but I think there is even a greater challenge to be had at this interface.
For instance, we currently now just build models that are specific to
individual aspects of cell physiology. That is we try to understand shape changes during
cell division or cell morphogenesis or cell migration but could we build a universal
model of cell mechanics that guides a cell in all its different shape changes
through its entire life span? Can we really understand all the versatility
in the cytoplasm that a cell experiences. Secondly, we have increasing knowledge of
the molecular details of cellular processes however these molecular details
do not confer the physical control parameters that are guiding the physics of
the cytoplasm. So we don't have these control parameters and
currently different models confer different amounts of importance to
different parameters and so these need to be rectified and we need to have
predictive theories that can then be experimentally tested
to see which one of these are correct.
Hopefully once we know the right control parameters,
it will give us increased understanding of how the cytoplasm confers
very robust responses in cells. That is, there ability to respond to a large range
environmental stimuli and undergo very dramatic shape changes.
It may even tell us how these very complicated cytoplasmic structures
evolved to give us such a beautiful mechanical responses.
And so these and many other questions at the interface of
cell biology and physics will give us lots of challenges for years to come.